lumbia university alumni medal for
distinguished service is presented to
Simon kaseylee 1970 School of Journalism
I received from the jealous in school
not only a very sound education one that
equipped me well for my career but it
opened the doors the gates of America to
me i arrived in 1969 the campus at
Columbia was buzzing with the previous
year's demonstrations I think the school
did wonderful things for me and very
often in journalism feels very much too
busy to make reflective decisions you
make reflexive decisions and it was in
those occasions when I thought well
there's somewhere in my subconscious was
the journalism school foundation that
served me in good stead the three main
things which are they the let's do it
better program where I had my eyes open
to a lot about the coverage of race and
racial issues the border border visitors
where I hope I have some input and
continued to to feel that I'm part of of
journalism and my experience as a bullet
Pulitzer juror I think when I got news
that I had been picked to receive an
alumni medal like my first thought was
perhaps this is what President Obama
felt like when they called him up and
said so you've been awarded the Nobel
Prize and thought no I die I didn't have
a commencement journalism in 1970 and I
thought to myself
somewhat soggy Tuesday this is my
commencement a little train 40 years
right but it was wonderful nonetheless